-It seemed like you focuse
your campaign
on big structural changes.
Obviously, a disappointing end
to the campaign.
Do you feel, though,
optimistic about
how some of those messages
were received
and the fact that
the country does seem to b
moving to a more progressive
point of view,
at least on some issues?
-Yeah, I do.
Yeah, I think that a lot
of what I talked about,
we have now seen
in the middle of this crisis
the importance of it.
So, for example,
student-loan debt
is something that
is just crushing
hundreds of thousands
of young people
and just an enormous drag
on them.
Social Security has not kept up.
Payments have not kept up.
And we have not adjusted
the Social Security system
to ensure that it's gonna be
financially viable
for long into the future.
Those are two issues which i
talked about over and over
And in the middle of this
crisis, you really are reminded,
students are supposed to b
making their
student-loan payments.
Now, finally,
we got into this bill
they have a six-month hiatus
on that.
But think about it --
this is a time
when the federal governmen
could step in and say,
"You know what?
We can't keep dragging dow
both these young people
and our economy
by not having --
because they've got
these huge
student-loan debt burdens.
So, it's something I want
to keep talking about.
Same thing on Social Security.
Now is the time that we should
increase Social Security
and disability payments
by $200 a month
on into the future,
and restructure how
we pay for Social Security
so Social Security
is gonna last
as far as we can see
into the future.
Those are the kind of
structural changes
that help support people
and help support our economy
And now that people
are under such pressure
and our economy
is under such pressure,
I think a lot of folks
are giving ideas like that
a second look 'cause I think
they're really important.
It's a change we've got to make.
-You were a candidate
who was known for having plans
what seems like
a lifetime ago now
but I believe was only January
You released a plan for how to
deal with infectious disease
like coronavirus.
Is this a plan you've considered
sending over to the White House?
Do you think
they would even look at it
And how was your plan differen
than the plan
that we've seen so far
out of D.C.?
-Well, you know, the main thin
about the plan is the timing
because when you're talkin
about a health crisis like this,
like an economic crisis,
much more important
to get in front of it
than chasing it from behind.
If we had put in place
an effective plan
to deal with the coronavirus
back in January,
we would have saved lives.
And we wouldn't put the stress
on our medical system
that we're putting on it
right now
and the stress on our economy.
This is one of those thing
we should've made the mask
and the respirators and usin
all of the federal tools
back in January to get started
not chasing it.
Here we are right at the end
of March, heading into April
and still haven't done
much of what we need to.
You know, for me, it's about -
it's what leadership is about.
It's about seeing the kind
of threats to the country
and seeing them early
and having a good,
thoughtful response to it,
having a plan for that.
I think that's
what will guide this country
and make this country safe
and make this country
all that it can be.
-Thank you so much
for being with us.
We're gonna let you get back
to Bailey and your TV show
and all your other
important work.
We hope to see you soon agai
back in the studio.
Really appreciate it.
-Me too.
It's good to see you, too.